[Music]  remember what we do is eliminate the  middleman and sell customer ordered pcs  made from stock parts direct to the  consumer that's it everyone with me good  nothing new to report at Dell we haven't  made any new computers yet so we'll just  keep selling the old ones for now okay  bye no this is just an early prototype  looks great thanks  don't you want us to turn it off no I  just start shipping but we need to make  great no you need to make it cheap what  is project NP a mousepad  free with every shipment who are we as a  company what do we stand for don't think  different think same and guys we gotta  make these laptops really thick with the  fans in the back so they can see them  cooling down some men not to change the  world  let me just yeah why would the e be like  that I don't know it doesn't matter  others don't really care about that  stuff  Michael Dell rated pg-13 start spreading  [Applause]  he's like nothing matters  [Applause]